ale it's under couch here and it's how
you choose a video we're not going to be
doing any coding
instead i wanted to make a video on some
goals i
have for data science in 2021
but before i start this um i wanted to
say that i
have a google form link
uh in the description because i am
running up towards my one year
anniversary for the title tuesday
project
and for that one year anniversary i want
to make a q a video
so i created a google sheets um or a
google form
sheet and you can just basically enter
in a name so you can say first name your
twitter
or your youtube username and you can
just ask me a question
and you know these questions kind of be
about like my background
data science as a whole you know advice
for
uh what class to take in college or you
know how to do interviewing and stuff
like that so
i figured i'd do that so you guys could
have asked me just anything what you
want anything you wanted
and i could go over that to form my one
year anniversary
so the five things that i'm going to be
looking at for data science in 2021
is mostly skill development so one of
the first things i really want to
emphasize
i really want to start learning is just
learning devops
so for me just as a data scientist i
really expected myself to mostly
doing like eda's modeling
um etc but i never expected to do any
deployment i thought you know we'd pass
it off to a devops team
however in my current role i'm basically
a full stack data scientist
so actually i have to use things like
docker kubernetes
uh flask etc and for me as someone who
really taught himself
taught myself how to do a lot of data
science projects through you know random
side projects where you don't actually
have to do a lot of deployment
i'm really not familiar with how to use
docker
i mean all those like containerizers and
stuff like that
so for 2021 i'm definitely focusing on
you know how to deploy my models onto
like an api
i'm into containers and etc so
i think i'll probably stick with docker
just because my team uses docker but i
also might do some flask
stuff so you're probably gonna see me
kind of look into using it
and maybe in doing it with like uh shiny
dashboards etc
um my fourth or my second skill that i
want to learn
is basically how to write more efficient
code
and i'm going to do it two ways the
first way is i'm going to probably just
do a bunch of lead coding
i definitely am not a solid programmer
at all but
i can do some basic beginner lead code
questions and i think they're pretty fun
so i figured i'd do
some weak code um throughout 2021
i'm also going to be looking at 538's um
the riddler
so let me see if there's a um which i've
made a video on
i think a few weeks ago so i'll probably
start working on like you know some
radar questions
um every other week um i might not make
a video on it but it's something that
i'll probably be working on
um throughout the year just to develop
uh some better
knowledge of how to write more efficient
code and just how to approach things
in a more creative way um that i'm not
used to such as just doing the
traditional charting and stuff like that
so for the leak code i think it just is
pretty helpful for a lot of data
scientists
is to like think of it as like a
software engineering um
discipline um i think a lot of people
think data scientists are more of a
stats discipline where i think it's
going to be more transitioning towards
you know software engineering uh so i
think
practicing software engineering uh best
use cases of
best practices it's probably a good idea
to
i'm kind of um future proof or at least
learn um the skills
before it starts transitioning towards
that software engineering path
um the third thing that i'm i want to
learn is something that i don't think is
very useful
in my field but i think it's pretty
useful
um if i want to do a lot of data
visualize visualizations which i like to
do as like a side hobby
which is to learn d3 uh d3 is like a
javascript language
basically made for charting so if you
look at like new york times 538 how you
see a lot of
really nice interactive charts um
they're not really written
in r but they're probably written in
like d3
um and i believe there are libraries
with d3 and r
that i think would be kind of
interesting to explore but i don't
really know how to use d3 at all
and i think it'd be a fun language to
learn just because
um it's a very i seem to me it seems
like a very rewarding language to learn
because
you get the instant gratification of a
nice looking chart
and what i really like about d3 is it
really forces
um people to use different charts that
aren't your traditional bar charts
scatter plots
you can do some interesting like uh
bubble charts
um i know there's a lot of like sancti
grams stuff like that so
i'm just gonna do a quick little google
thing and you can see there's a huge
selection of charts um they're pretty
cool and i think it'd be an interesting
a language to learn just casually and
nothing too serious but
um i think a lot of charts are really
cool and you know
you never know if you want to go into
like data journalism um i think learning
d3 is a pretty good asset to have
uh or if you're making very um uh very
uh productionalized dashboards d3 might
be a good
language to learn too i just find it
interesting because you can make a lot
of cool charts
um but it might be useful in the future
you never really know
so the fourth thing that i really want
to do is integrate data science
into my own hobbies and i think i can do
this in a bunch of ways
so i think a raspberry pi would be
pretty
fun to mess with and i think it'd be
kind of cool to you know start a project
you know make a model and put it in like
tensorflow
and then deploy it to a raspberry pi and
just put it around the house
so i think maybe buying a raspberry pi
since there's pretty cheap and just
doing some software engineering
uh you know maybe using some python that
i learned
and the past uh and during college and
then integrating with r
would be a cool thing to do um i also
think like
um for me as i really like coffee trying
to integrate
uh data science and machine learning
into coffee would be pretty cool um
coffee's definitely
an expensive hobby but things like this
where they have like a bunch of
sensor data with like the um pressure
and the
water temperature in espresso machine
would be kind of interesting to have
as a data scientist for someone to me
for someone like me who both
does a lot of data science and likes a
lot of coffee to kind of like do an
analysis of it
and see how i can like optimize my own
taste so i think just
integrating you know kind of kind of
some of my skills and data
science into some side hobbies that i
like to do
um that aren't direct to a related data
science would be kind of fun
um and it would be kind of a cool thing
to make a few videos on it
lastly my main goal for 2021 is to be
language agnostic
so for me i'm definitely a predominant r
user
um however i should probably learn a
little bit more python where
i can basically use python r
interchangeably
and one of the ways i'm going to do it
is probably just download one
um you know ide i think visual studio
code is a pretty good one
i know there's also pycharm but i have
vs code right now
and i've been using it at my work just
i'm messing around with it i don't want
to do any project i don't really do any
projects with it
but i definitely mess around on vs code
if i have some free time
so i think probably for 2021 you might
see a few python videos
uh probably not about just teaching
python but more about integrating
you know previous r users are users into
the python environments
so you know transitioning from like the
tidy verse uh using d plier
to like pandas or numpy and then
transitioning from like tidy models to
psychic learning kind of doing some
comparisons
um so that's basically one thing that
i'll definitely be focusing on is trying
to be more
a language agnostic you know really
sharpening my skills in python even
though i think python is a pretty
difficult language so learn like
academically
academically but using it as a data
scientist and putting it into your
projects
when you come from an our and tight
diverse background uh could be a
potential little challenging since it's
a different uh framework of programming
uh since it's like a class
object-oriented programming
so i think that's one thing i definitely
will be focusing on and i'm
i'm sure i'll make a few more videos on
you know python probably probably just
pandas scikit-learn and maybe some other
libraries but you know pretty simple
libraries that mostly everyone uses
in their data science stack so i know
this is a pretty
short video um i had christmas and now i
have new year's so i didn't want to do
a lot of coding but i will be making a
uh a dashboard our shiny dashboard video
about like modules and also make
i want to make a uh our shiny video on
comparing like flex dashboard
shiny dashboard and all those other
shiny dashboard frameworks
um in a more uh so i'll probably do that
in
a few weeks i will say that make sure
you write
uh you submit a question on my q a video
form in
uh the description uh because i'd like
to
get that video prepared but
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on